I got a call from an agent who wanted me
to go and audition for a new film called
The Empire Strikes Back
that was how I became a stormtrooper
this whole thing started because this
guy in our office is really into Star
Wars we all have one right after some
pretty serious internet sleuthing I've
tracked down this guy my name is Ralph
Morris he was a stormtrooper in Star
Wars episodes 5 & 6 that's the Empire
Strikes Back and Return of the Jedi I II
was in the get my shuttle ready sequence
I decided to carry my gun left-handed
sidesaddle
like I was carrying a shotgun in the
West and it's in the film you can see it
so we're talking about what it felt like
to be a stormtrooper and for the most
part that means what it felt like to
wear the costume I think all the
costumes were the same size and the
original model I think was about 5 foot
10 some of the guys who wanted a
terribly tall or terribly short found
the costume is unbearable and once
you're in this thing you can't really
get out of it you couldn't really sit
down at all you have to kind of lean to
one side and if you if you wanted to go
to the bathroom you needed to prepare
yourself you needed more than 30 second
warning okay but there is the helmet the
iconic helmet the first helmet they gave
me I couldn't see through the damn thing
at all the other problem we had were our
boots they had soles but they had no
tread in the soles so you would slide
all over the place I don't know a
stormtrooper who hasn't at some point
fallen over oh alright so it wasn't very
glamorous but it's still cool right cuz
you know Star Wars
you